this week
on the true jordi podcast
it's the face of gaming
[Music]
ninja oh my god dude
the best to ever have done get out get
out get out
going from the underdog going from the
guy during my entire come up on fortnite
for like a solid year
it was just love right and then to come
down from that high over the last year
all of it's gone because when you become
the champion everyone wants to say you
lose your title
you be inside by adidas you're doing
back-to-back pauses with beck
um do you feel like an athlete obviously
yes when you are the best at something
there should be no negativity towards
what you're the best at like you don't
even [__] understand what is actually
happening and what we are doing
and how good these people are that i'm
playing against how good that my team is
and we just sit down when we do it when
they bring an athlete on the tv show
like a beckham they don't make them do
[__] keep you up whereas with you
they're like
show us how you play the game it's
really annoying with alan i was always
like i really want i want to be on the
chair i want to i want to ask questions
i want to have a great conversation
because i
would i know i'd kill it and then you
know it's just like i have like a little
one minute we're playing britney spears
goes
on yeah she was able to sit in the chair
and and get that face time that she had
an announcement about an announcement
that was like it
and i found it quite interesting that
you had a detached record oh my god at
one point
like a couple more days or weeks they
said i would have been blind kept asking
every time i went back and i was like
well i'll be able to like really see out
of my eye like like actually good vision
boom the surgery i had to be away from
the whole thing which is terrifying i
had to look down for a month pretty sure
i i was depressed for a little bit now
with my mixer switch i'm really focused
on just uh providing good content
streaming and i've actually been a lot
happier the rumors were like 50 million
what was it like to be involved in a
deal like that
i'm not saying we were looking to leave
we definitely weren't we wanted to make
it work all of a sudden
on the most sort of family-friendly
biggest gamers you know account
there's [__] porn being advocates
right what the hell was your face like
when you seen that dude i lost my [__]
man
flossing with so many people oh [__] bro
you had to bring that up
one regret one regret dude they're all
gonna dance with you man
they they're out there they're wearing
diapers they're [__] themselves
they'll do anything
cold as [__] pouring rain
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
you're a tank dude you're a big guy as
well now i mean i mean i'm like yeah
i mean you're you're massive dude i
don't weightless that much actually i
just used to do a lot
you could you can film me no i so like
when i was in my early 20s i just went i
did loads
and then after that i just had to like
do a little bit just to stay there yeah
do you do like regular physical exercise
at all no man oh you're just
so [__] up i i run up and down my
stairs a lot that's about it
and uh that's pretty much like says i
got well yesterday we were at the adidas
uh the
new adidas flagship store and we were up
and down the stairs literally like ten
times
it was like six flights of stairs we
just kept going up and down and up and
down and i was like out of breath every
time
i met the ceo adidas and i'm literally
like like sweating on the way over yeah
that's
[__] mad is this guy an athlete or is
that uh
yeah it's so it's like it's so funny man
because it's like i'm here like i just
got you know picked up by adidas like
the last like couple months and
meeting the ceo and i'm like it is it's
a little
are we wrong do you kind of feel a bit
of a hypocrite having an adidas clothing
yeah i need to like get in shape for
real i need to be able to run up like
six flights of stairs and not be out of
breath
just ask beckham like what did he do
yeah i mean he played football
yeah what was it i'm eating him because
he's i mean he's an icon over here and
you used to play football
it was incredible man like i was i
didn't know what to expect right i i
kind of
just knew that i was going to meet him
right and and when he showed up i was
just like oh [__]
because he's got this kind of presence
as well too it was intimidating man i
mean dude he's got the
he's literally a dream man like top to
bottom
and uh and when i actually saw him i was
just like starstruck
yeah holy [__] david beckham oh my god
it's crazy i was like ha ha how you
doing man nice to meet you
he played 40 with his kids actually man
they hit me up on instagram like a year
and a half ago a year ago
wow i played offshore they're like
they're like yo man do you mind if we
play off stream though i was like
i don't care at all let's do it we just
game got some wins it was pretty cool
that's awesome yeah man so it's like
comes full circle is awesome and then he
threw me up on the instagram
story so i was just it must be so
surreal to look on your instagram and be
like
sorry i'm they're just they're just
signing off the camera show oh good man
to look on instagram and be like is that
my
my my face yeah
six 60 million followers yeah you post
about me
all right thanks bro in england he is
probably like the most famous guy he's
royalty based yeah
he's as famous as prince charles at
least so you've been inside by adidas
you're doing back-to-back poses with bec
um like two icons of their own world
right coming together
so like you you belong from an
outsider's point of view that makes
sense
but do you feel like you belong next to
a beckham it's a great question man
uh i think that it felt good when i was
next to him uh do i feel like i belong
next to him i don't know man he's got
like
dude he's again he's like you just said
i'm not royalty in america
right and he's royalty here and he's a
legend here and he's a legend everywhere
so um i mean i think it's too too soon
right i think a lot of stuff has
happened to me in the last two years and
i put the work in
but i haven't been as big as he has been
as big as he is for as long as he has
been so
i mean like realistically no it's kind
of strange isn't it because i think in
in a lot of other sports as well um
it that you get like a rookie year all
those kind of things yeah yeah yeah and
you
didn't really get a rookie year you just
saw it like a year i mean if you think
about it
and gaming and streaming i mean you put
in so much time it's crazy right like
i've been like i've been playing against
my entire life in 28 i was playing since
like four or five
and and streaming for now eight years
competing for ten years so
and like again like a lot of that's what
you said earlier ksi has been watching
for a long time
everyone thinks i just came up yeah it's
like dude no way man i've been i've been
grinding this is a real journey yeah
it's just that the spotlight hasn't been
on gaming or me
and you're making that happen now and
the one thing that strikes me is when
they do put you
on the tv shows with ellen and whoever
else i'm sure something a lot of times
when they bring and this is the thing i
think you're breaking down the barriers
but they're still there
because they're definitely when they
bring you on a tv show when they bring
an athlete on the tv show
like a beckham they don't make them do
[__] keep you ups right whereas with
you they're like
play the show it's how you play the game
it's really annoying is that
is that annoying is it i mean i don't
mind it because i know what i'm doing i
know that i'm doing it for the people
who don't understand like
there aren't a bunch of kids and gamers
who are watching the ellen show and
watching like jimmy fallon
even though they're great shows
obviously but like they're not the
audiences
you're doing a favor for us right as the
gaming fans in
breaking those barriers down but it is a
bit like i don't know i could only
compare it i remember
yeah chimp so like when bodybuilders i
remember
back in the day would be on a show
they'd go right well get you
show us what you've got yeah like it's a
little bit like that and that's
because gaming is still sort of like the
subculture and not
mainstream but you are the first
mainstream gamer yeah this is a great
way to put it man by the way
i i felt weird when i was on shows and
i'd watch other shows
that's a great that's a great uh person
not perception
yeah obviously observation thank you man
really is because it was weird for me
watching that because i was like
yeah i feel like i know what it would be
like to be him right now
because you're doing everyone a favor or
who's on who where on your team is the
online community
but at the same time or they are they
giving you the respect you deserve
right oh man because i was i was there
without and i was always like i really
want i want to be on the chair i want to
i wanted to ask questions i want to have
a great conversation because i would
i know i'd kill it but and then you know
it's just like i have like a little
one minute we're playing yeah and then
you know i see
britney spears goes on and and she dude
i'm sorry i have to say it's the
stupidest [__] man she goes on there to
announce that she has an announcement
yeah she was able to sit in the chair
and and get that facetime
that she had an announcement about an
announcement and then and i think that
was like it
and and she just like left after that we
don't even know what the announcement
was
and we don't even know we're sitting
there going i've been on a gym like i've
got [__] to say here yeah if you give me
the chance i actually can deliver for
you here
but you're not even entertaining the
idea that this man
might have something to say yeah so it
was really unfortunate i was a i was a
little salty about it but obviously of
course i get it
you know i'm not i'm not pretty serious
but people have
like said this about you like uh because
now there's so many eyes on you
yeah any time you say anything that
might be classed as like
controversial you deserve something
because you're the first mainstream
gamer
you've got to be grateful for everything
you're not allowed to act like i've
earned this
yeah the minute you start going yeah i
[__] earned this yeah you're too good
now
and then they want to bring you down
have you felt that yet i mean i just
know that
yeah definitely felt that i need to just
completely stay i mean i always will
stay humble but i need to always act it
as well
and and make sure that uh i never have
that that
i don't know i don't even know if i want
i don't know if i want i don't know if i
want to feel like i've earned this like
maybe in front of my family my wives and
my my wives my wife
in front of my family i i definitely
feel that way i feel confident that i've
earned it and they
and they make me feel like that um can
you imagine any other job though
where you know if you're going for a job
evaluation you just work in a normal
office and they they're like
welcome uh yeah tyler am i right yeah
okay
um do you feel like you've earned this
job and you're like i've i've been
typing i mean i've done some good admin
i feel recently and they're like but
have you really earned it like that
would be a really weird thing right you
know what i mean
no other no i'm just talking about this
because i feel like i
know where i am and i'm quite proud of
the but i feel like
because i'm a bit of an underdog i can
act that way right whereas when you are
the top dog in your field it's not
people don't like it when you conor
mcgregor it a little bit
and i'm not suggesting you go that far i
never will ever
saying no to ellen and saying for
example
look i've done the first thing but next
time you know i want to be trek the same
as everyone else and actually have a
[__] interview
yeah if you started acting i just wonder
how people would perceive it so as it as
as a well i don't think they would see
that side you don't see that side of
people right that would be my team
reaching out telling
me being like hey you know tyler's not
going to come on the show like that
won't ever go public unless you know
i were to say it but no i think you're
absolutely right and i've literally
witnessed
going from going from the underdog going
from the guy during my entire come up on
fortnite
and getting nothing but love from
everyone i mean my timeline
like this is like before the drake stuff
during the drake stuff after the drake
stuff
for like a solid year it was just love
compliments proud of you you're doing
like you're killing it you're repping
the gaming community like
just non-stop i was like this is
incredible
right and then to come down from that
high over the last year where it's like
all of it's gone no like i mean i have
to i feel like i got a
smd to get like one compliment from
someone now like
good job ninja you know why what do i
have because when you become the
champion
everyone wants to say you lose your
title and that's the side
it's like i watch the ufc the minute
someone looks like he's unbeatable
everyone wants him to lose and that's
basically where you are now it sucks man
because it's like
i don't even i'm not even like competing
as as much anymore right so it's not
like i'm it's not like i'm like a lebron
or michael jordan like i'm not like
trying to hold my title as the number
one
gamer in the world like because that's
the thing it's not like i dominated the
the esports scene for like seven years
right and won a bunch of tournaments
it's like i was just like the most
popular
fortnight gamer right which makes you
even harder to take down almost because
you can't yeah it's not a results-based
you're entertaining people and you're a
competitor but you're you're not able to
be dethroned now because you own
you've nailed it as the first mainstream
game right they can't take
you because there were so many things
that had to align
what is it that you think if anything
made you the guy
and other guys didn't get that dude i
saw the game and i was like this is fun
this
this game looks sick and i went into all
the top streamer streams like
summit lyric i was watching all of them
play on twitch and i was watching them
and they were like nah man the game's
not game's not it game's not fun
and i'm looking at it like this game's
incredible i don't know what they're
talking about
once they once uh they update released a
accuracy update on the scars and like
the weapons and stuff like that i'm fine
i was like all right now i'm gonna start
grinding it i started playing it and it
was just
dude i think it was i was one of the
first i was a relatively big streamer i
was averaging five ten thousand viewers
like every day so
i already had the exposure and then once
i started just playing it for a solid
month
like i saw an initial dip in viewers
because i was playing pub g before that
and then after it was just non-stop
growth for the next year
and it was i think it was because i was
known as one of the best fortnite
players
right when it came out yeah but
personally i don't take the same opinion
that everyone else does that you were
made by your game
because looking at you though and i'm a
bit like this when you have that level
of determination
it's a matter of time man right being
another game like
it would have been another game yeah i
mean i've heard interviews with you
where you're like
i was watching this i was watching that
the level of attention to detail that
you have or pr
not just for playing games but for
watching trends watching what people are
responding to
like you would have done it anyway so i
don't subscribe to the fortnight made
you don't get me wrong
great that it came along when it did oh
hell yeah big fan
what i mean is like personality will
start everything about you
what what is it if there's one
ingredient that goes in
the you as a bloke as tyler yeah what is
it that made you the guy
opposed to everyone else uh the the the
hybrid of
of being entertaining and being good at
the game that's the number one thing
that
number the two number one traits that
you need to be a top streamer and
youtuber if you're like a gamer right
you have to be really good
because you have to be able to teach
people you have to be able to just be so
effing good that you entertain them
like just literally by watching you they
don't even you don't even need to talk
they can watch your game play you're
[__] on kids so hard
that they're entertained right but if
you can also on top of that
be like freaking out and reacting which
is really hard
oh yeah as you see yeah man you were
getting lost in you i'm a big person
when i'm on a game [__] it's off do
you know what i mean it's also because i
lose otherwise if i'm not concentrating
whereas you
are so good you don't have to you can
just be like yeah what were you saying
yeah that is quite interesting because i
think you've got a similar quote to what
we do like five six hour live streams at
a time but watching football
you were saying if you're on a 10-hour
live stream you are yourself like you've
got to completely relax because you
can't keep that facade of pretending
i'll tell you something
i mean i i love youtube i do i watch all
the time
but you know [__] youtube you like
youtubers i mean like just look at all
of like the top like not all i don't
wanna and obviously i'm not calling
anyone out specifically but
dude yeah you know like literally it's
like okay we're recording
recording yo what's going on guys and
then
and then it's like okay wait a minute
you guys want to redo that one yeah yeah
yeah
and then and and like you literally
create
what you want people to to to see you as
and as a streamer it's the exact it's so
so much harder bro like it is so hard
you are it's you that's it 10 hours like
i can't i'm not going to fake my
being a personality for 12 hours every
single day of my life
and you can't do it no and that's also
what blows dude is like god the amount
of clickbait i had
on on twitch bro because the controversy
you gonna [__] up man you're gonna say
something you shouldn't say
and like and like dude like i said some
[__] with drake and uh and and it got
picked up on and i was like and i
immediately as i said it
i was like you know what dude nah nah
that's not it but like
can i pull those yeah literally i was
like i mean dude you say [__] that you
just don't
mean sometimes like literally i'm like
well i literally was like why do i even
say that
that's not true and then i literally
said nah man that's
get out not all do what you've just said
though we all have we have conversations
in our head where we go
yeah i think they start the other and
then you you play it back and you go
i'm talking [__] yeah you know but when
you're saying out loud on a twitch
stream and you've done
literally thousands of hours of it i
mean that's it
yep not only that but you're you're also
concentrating on two things
so a lot of people i think speak in
their daily lives the only thing you got
to concentrate on is saying the words
you're not also being asked to then play
a competitive game at the same time and
be like
high level as well yeah well not to
mention you're you're playing right
you're
zoned in you're focused you're maybe
even talking to someone in the game that
you're playing with
and then someone like donates a message
you half read it
yeah right you give a half response to
it
and and you're just like [__] dude you
didn't read and then you're just wait
wait handle let me reread that again and
then they
they don't care about that part that
part's like all cut out which is why
dude being youtuber is
a lot easier too though absolutely like
jesus absolutely you
see they see what you i mean dude you
see that when the one clip of the girl
accidentally uploaded
the dog the dog i knew they were going
with that
social media long edited version so this
girl this girl basically
accidentally uploaded the unedited
version of her being with she was like a
[__]
basic youtuber and she was beating her
dog up spitting on her dog treating like
[__]
she accidentally uploaded that and you
see like the real hair right but
and this we about a year ago i sat on a
podcast like youtubers are actors like
you think you know them
you don't [__] that is that is a
youtuber literally right there what you
just saw like that like the unedited
like
[__] um okay hey guys
and then like [__] out yeah yeah if you
take logan for example like
um if you watch the logan uh vlogs from
ages ago and then logan on his podcast
yeah i mean there's two different people
oh 100 so i think he's also
decided that he wants to not be that
crazy absolutely
but he's a good example for that but no
i mean dude there's um
tmz footage of like of jake paul doing
you know
recording youtube video right and you
see and it's they're just watching him
and he's recording and then you see him
like
he literally he's like okay go guys
what's up man he's like holding the
camera up and then
and then you they nah now he puts it
down and then he like gets up again
yo and then they're like all right we're
good we're done and then like they just
like walk away yeah and like that
where's that energy yeah like that's not
the person that they are all the time
and that's and that's 95 percent of
youtubers
that's not necessarily wrong but if
you're a piece of [__]
in real life and you're pretending to be
this like i mean it's
it's fake man did you find that when you
were first streaming uh
do you think do you think the the
streamer you
and the normal you have sort of come
together the exact same person dude i
don't really i don't the only thing i
turn off now is
is swearing a lot and and that took a
long time of like
i mean to do the language man like the
gaming lingo
you know what i'm saying you could
pretty much say whatever you wanted to
back in the day i mean you see those old
call of duty modern warfare lobbies
where you're
just calling each other a bunch of homo
[__] and like yeah yeah and like and
then at the end of the game it's like oh
gg man
yeah it's like no one actually means
what they're saying
but yeah i mean i was saying like yeah
it's bad [__] yeah that's the only thing
i turn off now it's very easy are you
ever worried about that coming about to
haunt you because now you are the
guy super bad you know just like like i
mean yeah just some really
ratchet [__] nothing wrong nothing like
nothing racist nothing ever crazy but
like yeah i'm like elf you know f you in
the ass
bro yeah you know who said it we've all
said it we all said it dude like am i
actually gonna go to this dude and and
you know have
some bro stuff going on absolutely not
there's a zero percent chance yeah and
am i beating zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero one zero point zero four
it was a very repeating i mean there's
always this very low possibility yeah
i mean never say never yeah exactly you
never know
i do find that interesting though
because i also feel like if you're not
part of that generation you don't really
get that thing you don't yeah
at all and so parents will sometimes
probably watch and be like
their kids are just they understand it
yeah and all but also again
and this is why i really cleaned up my
language too and like how i was talking
is because
you know anyone from the age of five to
15. i mean [__] bro i wouldn't start i
didn't start thinking for myself so i
was like late 20s
um they won't know if i'm being serious
or not which is like which is why
which is why those youtubers i keep
bringing them up and there's nothing
wrong with it i want to keep saying that
like it's it's even more important for
them to
to be good examples because these kids
they they see that
and it's a facade but they don't know
that it's a facade and they see it and
they're like oh this is that person this
is some youtubers who whenever i have
anything to do with them whether i'm in
their videos
or uh talk about them or anything like
that as much as
i know them yeah we're cool their
audience
they've bought into every single thing
so like my dms instantly blow up
full of like 14 year old sort of
iranian kids who are questioning their
sexuality and they're just saying
mad [__] about me like and i'm like like
every time i do anything
with do you know what i mean do not piss
off if it becomes
one thing i'm taking away from you it is
it is difficult
uh do you class yourself as a role model
now then
100 man of course i mean i see so many
kids all the time like little kids man
like five-year-old six-year-olds and
that's actually one thing that i don't
even think
like i have a young audience man but i
have an older audience too
but they're i mean they're like
five-year-olds wearing like ninja merch
and stuff like we have merch
and uh in primark here we have it all
over london um
and and now going a lot more over europe
and there's like the youth stuff bro
it's been like flying off
flying off the shelves it's like dude
this five-year-old doesn't know
what you know anything is anything
there's no [__]
he's walking around with an introvert
you're almost it's a cartoon like now in
terms of like how branded you've become
i like that by the way that's kind of
what we're going for you've kind of
become like uh
like an icon in that regard you know
you're not even
the guy anymore you're a symbol for what
they like that was as much as
and that was all the master plan a
hundred percent when once
once like six six months like blowing up
massive i'm averaging like a hundred
hundred thousand viewers
every single day and then fortnite kind
of like slowly started to go down
we knew it would right obviously and
which it happens with everything
i was like all right how are we going to
solidify like you know me as
as the gamer the streamer the fortnite
whatever and it was just making ninja
uh one of the things i wanted to do was
definitely be more like cartoony
ish like not i don't want to say not a
person
but you're brought up like a character
yeah right and that's what we're we're
doing a lot of stuff
like broadness genius bro thank you man
well done
you know it's funny i got so much [__]
for like it's people don't know me man
so many people think i stopped swearing
and everyone's like oh he's selling out
because
he wants to make money off little kids
it's like the [__] wrong with you i i
don't want to i don't want a little
five-year-old running around screaming
you know a bunch of profanities
yeah yeah like like for example
i'm the bad guy yeah yeah exactly you're
not the it's the direction that you were
already in
like they're watching you anyway with me
five year olds aren't watching a [__]
podcast right so i can say whatever
whatever i want but if i was in your
position in the big blue house they
think it's that
but if i was in your position and i i
had them there you got to make the
adjustments
you almost didn't have much of a choice
yeah it's not like it i don't
think it changes your content all that
much though because i think
i mean there's you gotta watch some my
old videos man
well you were quite wild why you yeah i
literally i
i like i get so i get so like i blush
bro when i'm like holy [__] oh yeah
some of them i was like that came out of
my mouth man i mean
but dude it's just i was i love gaming
so much i love talking [__] and that
like that was one of my ways of
entertaining
right was and this was dude again this
was before like little kids even really
really got into gaming like blowing up
like four and i changed all that
like h1z1 pubg i was dude like my
average audience was 18 for sure like 16
to 20 something they're much more
serious as well i feel like maybe
fortnite kind of helped you do that
because it is a bit more animated
if you've come up or you're on halo or
something or you know you're like a
really serious game
yeah you almost can't break out and be
cartoony because it's just so odds with
what i'm actually doing i tried really
hard to do that
in halo reach i was doing one me once
and that's what i was known for just
being a [__] goofball
it was really difficult in 4v4s because
there's a lot like i'm worried about
four people's spawns and what and all
that [__] but when i was just one person
like i knew all the spawns i only have
to worry about one guy and if i have all
the power weapons i can be the biggest
douche in the world and just like goof
around and that's what so
i'm kind of fascinated how your brain
works because there's clearly something
going on with this brain that makes you
this because
no one else is that good pretty much
like yeah i'm sure there's competitive
gamers out there probably watching
they're all attacking again but you're
[__] way better than the average
person like me
how do you is there's thought patterns
that you think you've got that enable
you to be [__] great at gaming is
there something that you do
that's a great question man i think it
really just time in and practice
like i put in i've been gaming my entire
life right so on
on pc on xbox i played playstation i
played sega dreamcast
uh sega genesis everything n64 you name
it i've played it i've held a controller
so i think
all that and then just playing so many
different games it's like
it's excessive yeah i mean i'm obsessed
with video games for sure in a good way
um clearly but if you play enough
video games and playing genres you
pretty much just it just stays in my
head i know how to play every game now
right so if i play a new fps it's going
to take me
all i need to know is the movement the
movement's the only thing i really have
to learn the weapons are going to be
pretty simple
and then unless it is every game the
same almost i mean fps's and and
uh stuff right i mean yeah absolutely do
you ever dream about gaming because
every night of my life really i mean i
dream so much about i go to bed right
now and all i see
oh for the last because i'm screaming
and practicing a lot in fortnite lately
to to compete again and all i see are
edits
like really when you like edit a window
in a door and all that [__] like i
literally go to bed and i just i i box
myself i'm not in my head i box myself
into a pyramid and then like i like edit
in my head
it's weird man i can't stop either i
can't stop thinking about it man
i i think everyone's had that at some
point we've played enough of a game
you've definitely had it with gta
where you start to like imagine the
mobile phones don't get out of cars
yeah people with bets
but it's also like that's another story
you start to get
that like as a kid i remember being like
oh my god i'm so obsessed with this game
i can't wait to wake up in the morning
you also start to think that that's like
real life so you start to think you can
do those
not in like a weird way there is that
kind of strange like
i had moments where i was like rpgs
maybe yeah never shooters
but definitely yeah i played final
fantasy 11 and mmo for like 12 years of
my life and i
yeah i was like dead i wish this game
was relevant have you ever had uh
interviewers come at you on the the link
between video games and violence in
america it's all that stupid you ever
heard that
all the time yeah i mean with a lot of
like uh uh
the older the boomers yeah yeah cause
they don't that's uh and that's the only
thing they can see
video games and violence like listen
dude all right it's [__] simple don't
let your 10 year old
play radar game okay just like you
wouldn't let your 11 year old walk in
and watch saw all right what do you
think's gonna happen like they're super
impressionable and they shouldn't be
watching people get sawed in half and
like
tortured and like that's going to mess
them up man whereas fortnight is i think
foreign is is so cartoony
and so it's so distant it's so there's
no blood there's when you get eliminated
your guy like falls over and like
just kind of like evaporates like it but
he gets like sucked up by like a little
robot
yeah and then like he just kind of like
disappears you can't believe this is
real basically yeah yeah
it's not no it's not there's no dude
it's not man and like another thing with
violence man
or not violence but like when a kid
freaks out in a video game it's like if
you're
would you be pissed if your child lost
in basketball or football
um football and and like got really mad
after
like would you would you be like you
need to calm down
right like you just lost you lost the
clutch game uh it was one it was 2-1
you blew the lead some [__] like and now
your son's mad
like you're no matter what age like are
you gonna be as a parent be like
you need to calm down but if you lose in
a video game and someone literally just
dominated you
and you take that competitively as well
and your kid starts to you know kind of
get mad and freak out a little bit it's
like it's literally the same thing
competition now there's a little too
obviously you know there's rage and then
there's anger
yeah but competition's big to you do you
think there's been a bit of an attack on
uh competition in the youth because i
don't know about in america but like
there's things that they're doing away
with in this country where they're like
you know
um is it sports day and [__] they're
changing sports day so it's all about
like
we have like a kids olympics at schools
in here sometimes okay
and they've been like doing away with
that [__] such a great way of saying
yeah just just just to do away with it
because kids can't take losing and [__]
like this
and uh we're too soft man yeah i think
competition's great for a kid
competition is everything right i think
that's part of it
it feels [__] it can ruin some people
like that's part of the problem is i
think that they're
they're trying to like they're trying to
minimize life [__]
get used to it it's literally you can't
do it though
bro think about it man like it's like
this take your take i love this
and just thinking like this bro like get
remove this remove this building remove
society remove
the government remove all that [__]
we'll live in the wild okay
you're gonna get eaten or you're gonna
eat like you're gonna kill this tiger or
he's going to kill you and i'm saying
like
that's how it is and that's how that's
how we're programmed that's how we were
literally
that's how we evolved was just survival
right we're literally slowly taking away
those
like oh you don't like to whoosh it's
okay
uh you know [__] about the fact that
you've killed them in a game before
all the time yeah you talk oh you mean
like people like just raging maybe
you're the other big
online personality oh or or even just
kids rage he hadn't spoken to drake in
five years
it's been forever no uh dude yeah i mean
i don't i don't think anyone
this one kid was like really like in in
competitive so i was like spraying him
across the map
like during like the late zone rotation
he like tweeted at me and was just like
i know you're new to this so here's a
pro tip and like gave me something
i was like did you oh i i replied i was
like thank you for the professional
advice and like smiled and i was like
what an idiot man
but the online personalities no one big
i don't think anyone big has ever like
bitched me for killing anything like
that i don't think that's
it's wrong to go the person at the very
top yeah it's like that's the hardest
don't go for the king if you miss
it so you're hard to miss against me
everyone is uh it hates me on youtube
man it's
besides besides like you like it's so
weird man i've seen the talk videos on
you i did watch a video i'm not gonna
say who did them because obviously
that's what they're hoping they're also
good friends
uh they're definitely not they're not um
i watch one kid who's really moaning
about you a lot
when you watch a video like that i don't
watch them uh have you not watched that
i can't
just ignore them yeah when because
they're just wrong they don't know me
yeah
and they don't know like dude like when
i made the switch over to mixer man
so many there's just one dude on twitch
he's in the biggest douche i've ever
seen my entire life
and he just made this video rant and
literally i listened to like 30 seconds
of it and the first 30 seconds was all
[__] and all
the wrong reasons and i just didn't
listen to the restaurant i must admit
that that's the one thing if you're
making a full and complete argument
about something i've done wrong and you
say
well these are the good points these are
the bad points and then this is the
conclusion
but what they tend to do is very
politician like where they give you
half an argument only the stuff that
benefits what they're saying
and ignore all the actual truth a lot of
the time nothing i can even do about it
man
like i i can't it's so stupid like
there's so many videos on youtube that
i can't i can't address them all that
they're all that like take just
little things and it's just like bro
like i had a kid
come up to me on halloween two years ago
and we were running out of candy and i
was like yeah i mean you guys want some
signed ninja merch and they were like oh
my god
dude that'd be amazing went in the house
grabbed some sign ninja merch gave it to
him
and they're like man all our friends
said you were total dick man
you're not mean at all i'm like what
kind of [__] videos are these kids
watching [__] t-shirts right give me
that [__] back
yeah like dude so it's so tell them tell
me where they live yeah
kids just like who knows who knows what
videos are watching like how many people
think i'm just like this big douche
it's like i can't trust the territory a
little bit i guess
yeah the bigger you get no one's making
[__] videos by david beckham
[__] david beckham you know and here's
why
he kicked a dog two weeks later some
dude's like [__] you david
i know you kicked that dog like that
that doesn't happen no one makes
i want to get to that level i want to
hit i'm trying to hit i'm trying to hit
i've been talking
with my team about this trying to hit
rock level right eventually where it's
like the dude could
[__] on the street and people would just
be like unbelievable
i couldn't smell what the rock is [__]
dwayne like dude he's just he's
untouchable in the greatest way he's
such a good person so funny you should
mention him i was literally like looking
at his instagram earlier today and i was
like
this guy's having the best life of all
it's the greatest man he works out he's
just a great dude he does great things
for people
and like i do i do i feel like i do
great things for people
he's too perfect though he's too how
does he achieve
like kills babies i feel like you know
those movies
like a time stop and he can do more in
the day like he seems to do so much with
his days and i'm certainly like i'm
sitting on my
underpants at like 11 a.m you know what
i mean the thing is he is in his
underpants but he's just working out
it's just that he's just been working he
just looks like five hours straight yeah
and he's eating ten thousand kids
though i do wonder that with you because
actually when you see
when like chatting to you now you're a
little bit sarcastic you're quite funny
yeah
the rock thank you can't you're a little
bit funny
the rock cannot go out there and just
have a day where he's like
[__] all this [__] like i don't want to
do like you're quite loose and you're
being yourself yeah i feel like the rock
is always in there
oh my god you're actually he's in this
mode of like movie star
all the time maybe he's just maybe
that's just him dude but people don't
realize
he wakes up and he's just like all right
yeah you know like you do get to think
the rock maybe could be that one guy who
does that
just i'm just gonna go off to topic yeah
sure the rock you know you met him one
day yeah and he lent in from this
do you kiss him oh absolutely i'd kiss
him yeah i i think i'd probably
if he sets the tongue in do you i don't
know about that come on
we've only just met the people's tongue
okay fair enough yeah
he is handsome though yeah if you're
gonna go though i'm just saying would
you take a bit of a rock bottom
that's all i'm asking all right jesus
christ man these parties
we're talking about you being an athlete
earlier i do find this sort of debate
or um or game can gamers be athletes i
don't expect us to do that because we
could do that for an hour but
do you feel like an athlete absolutely
like
uh people just don't i don't know man
obviously yes like
when you when you it's like this dude
when you are the best at something
like it you shouldn't even there should
be no negativity towards what you're the
best at like
no just because we're not running miles
doesn't mean we're not literally the
best of what we're doing like i'm
playing fortnite right let's say i'm the
best player in the world at fortnight we
just won a bunch of tournaments
and someone's like oh no you're sitting
down man real real
real good job it's like you don't even
[__] understand
what is actually happening and what we
are doing and how good
these people are that i'm playing
against how good that my team is and
it's like they don't they don't see that
they see the
older generation really sees people oh
you're just sitting down and it's like
dude
you don't understand the only difference
between
esports and actual i say actual jesus
christ
um then athletes that are like you know
your typical you know you're running
around your football
american football all that [__] is is
that we just sit down when we do it
all right that's literally the only
difference everything that's going on up
here mentally like the the mental
preparation
the the time in the hours is the exact
same i think your mentality is very
very athletic like as in like the eye of
that exactly
you have to you have to and again it's a
bit like archery and it's a bit like
um people who play snook iron or the um
hand-eye coordination
sports to me their cluster sport um to
me if snook has a sport if arteries are
sport
gaming there's literally a sport there's
literally
it's not these people are in the in the
freaking gym doing like finger curls
yeah and it's like this guy is athletic
that's the off season during the season
come on man hit the gym like that it's
not like
seriously like look at that pure
athleticism right there it's like
dude shut up do you ever think though
because you can obviously look back and
uh you know when you first thought when
a football club was set up or when
basketball first started or whatever
it looks so basic when you look back
then and you're like
look at the way even the kits look
different those kind of things yeah you
kind of wonder whether because you're in
that first wave of people
people it's it almost feels generational
yeah you're at the very start of it
yeah like in 50 years time you're going
to be i don't know if you know who this
is but like pele
yeah like we have a all player in
football who's like the the original go
like you're going to be looked upon but
like maradona
the original if i if i can't if i will
be if that is
i hope so man that's why that's all i i
want that maybe don't be like pele
though because he did viagra
all right yeah and that got a bit weird
we got the blue hair
it's a natural integration right now
easy listen boys when you're hitting the
mid-30s you know what i mean
you see me advertising a pill man i've
hit rock bottom
pills coming big money i've lost all
my saved up revenue i'm broke do you
ever think about
uh because obviously you get to meet a
lot of people you must get to meet a lot
of ceos people who are just sort of
you know they they love gaming but they
also love technology those kind of
things do ever think about where gaming
is going and kind of
the evolution of that because i want it
to just be full-blown
like put put a headset on like like a vr
headset on and like go and do a world
that's my that's my dream i want to be
alive i want to be alive and i think i
will be
60 years we got that in the bag but i'm
trying to i'm trying to be alive when i
can just full
you know ready player one that [__]
let's be honest though you got the money
for cryogenic freezing so you
you'd be good if you if you want to wait
it out yeah it's not actually
good i feel like it's she probably does
though it definitely does
do you awesome powers you're not seeing
it the point is
when when you get to that point where
it's not a true story when you're
putting a headset on and stuff
that then is much more like real sports
because you maybe have to build a
character up or those kind of things
i think the lines between the two might
get a little bit blurred by like 20
30. here's what i think i think it
doesn't matter i think that
the older generation's opinions don't
matter because
they'll be dead soon just like just like
when
do you know like another another sport
comes up in the next 20 years when we're
old and and we are like no this isn't a
sport
this isn't esports this isn't whatever
it's like just like our opinions won't
matter
we'll be [__] dead it's like who
cares we don't like
dude gaming does not need old people we
don't need old people
no like we really know i love i
obviously i love old people i love i
love every generation
without bill gates you wouldn't be
playing like 50 euthanasia all the way
down to the euthanasia oh isn't it what
do they call it no it's euthanasia is it
all right
i'm saying we're dominating like the
gaming industry is absolutely dominating
we don't need any
we don't need an older audience so you
know everyone's always like
trying to justify it to the older
generation i was just like dude it
doesn't matter just wait 10 years we're
fine
do you ever i mean you probably do i
mean i i experience this anyway because
we do a lot of live streaming not as
much as you
yeah do you ever get burned out and just
need breaks or
it only when like there's a lot of
negativity that's going on all right i
can i can stream and grind
forever i can play video games forever
um
it's when yeah there's like some drama
involved and [__] like that where i need
to like
step away or you know i find that as
well yeah mentally
strong as it gets but like there's times
i'm like dude
away from me the human mind is not made
for millions of people
to know about them and to watch them do
things and talk [__]
yeah do you ever you know because i
don't know about you but when i say the
zeros next to a view button i'm like
yeah i don't even think about it but
like obviously
the level you're at now it just it must
be almost unavoidable sometimes to be
aware of it
oh dude i'm it's also really important
to understand your your numbers and your
views like you have to
you can i can't i can't just like you
know turn off my i can't just completely
pay quite a bit of attention to the
stats and stuff don't you
yeah you have to man um i think now now
with my mixer switch i'm actually
i'm not i'm really focused on just uh
providing good content streaming and
i've actually been a lot happier
so that's been really nice just like can
we talk about that i loved you man yeah
um
because from from my point of view uh i
look at whenever
um ksi and logan for example break
through
get a huge deal with uh with the p
review thing i'm like this is great for
everyone yeah you're helping everyone
here
and when i've seen that i was like mate
you're doing all sort of things by doing
this because you're giving the power
back to the
to the gamer yeah if and this isn't and
you know not on twitch but like you know
you're proving the worth
of the the creator there uh what was it
like to be involved in a deal like that
dude it was uh i mean dude
groundbreaking game changing that's what
we and it was what we wanted to do
i'm not saying we were looking to leave
we definitely weren't we wanted to make
it work um it was actually just
uh it was a very difficult process man
for uh for a lot you know eight months
sick i don't know i don't even know what
i'm allowed to say but uh
yeah if we tried to make it work didn't
work and we're like
with twitch yeah so there was
renegotiations going on and then uh and
then they break down before you talked
to mixer or did mixer come in no we i'm
we gave him like a lot we gave him so
many like hey
listen what are you guys doing like
we're not asking for a lot mm-hmm
and i'm not even talking about money
like it wasn't even we were we just
wanted
like a little bit more freedom and they
just weren't budging and then
we were we talked with mixer and it was
like bro
two weeks and then and all the
negotiations were like all right
like perfect done wow wow it was so
simple so quick did you have any
apprehension about that though because
it's fair to say that mixer wasn't as a
platform the size of twitch
it's not even close the the statistics
are like they get like five percent of
the viewership and and that wasn't what
i was really worried about i i knew
what i knew what it was going to do for
a lot of other streamers and a lot of
other gamers and that was like
that was like what i kept telling myself
in the back of my head obviously the
deal was great
and and um and i really do love the
platform it's incredible but i knew i
was like my wife and i we went into this
like
we're doing this for everyone else it's
gonna be and look what happened man we
got people being resigned to twitch we
got people moving to youtube and now
more people being signed and making
deals and it's like it's how it should
be
it's also pretty amazing though because
when i flipped on my xbox yesterday
um my xbox one um i
you're there like right at the very top
it's like cool now which is
you're getting like when i put my phone
on i've got to kind of navigate there
when you put your xbox on and you're on
the very front page of it
that's almost like another level yeah
just to go back to the deal
uh because obviously at one point uh you
were
you know naturally like we all do we we
we're going to get deals and they're
coming to us it's a bit of both
and at this point you're now the most
sought after guy
i mean let's even logan and jj
and pewdiepie like you are the guy right
now that all the brands won because
you've
got this sort of value that no one else
has uh
to go from those deals back in the day
which were obviously a lot smaller to
now like they're begging for you
and you're basically calling your shots
yeah um
what was it like to be in that position
it was really nice
yeah i mean yeah it's pretty much
did they make you feel wanted and good
stuff as opposed to twitch
[__] you around yeah mixing me up
that's all dude it was it's like dude
that was my home
i don't want to get too into it but like
that was my home yeah and and to to
struggle like we did to to come to like
an agreement for as long as we did it
was like
really you know like what the [__] man
so
but then we went over you know make sure
they were just like it was so easy it
was so
awesome and i've been uh at their
studios and i'll talk to
a lot of their higher-ups and it's just
a it's just great company man and
they're really passionate about it
but for those who don't know because
people might not know that yeah this was
like an unprecedented
deal like the rumors i'm not going to
ask you what they were but they were the
rumors were like 50 million
and all sorts of numbers wow that's
mind-blowing huge huge
huge numbers that are like ground
breaking like no
like let's not be you broke [__]
records yeah
absolutely um and the problem the sad
thing was
i think that twitch handled it really
badly after as well
like clearly about it yeah take it out
and all of a sudden
on on the most sort of family-friendly
biggest gamers
you know account there's [__] porn
being advertised right
what the hell was your face like when
you seen that well we didn't so
we we knew that they were advertising
other streams every single top stream on
my stream on my actual
page and i wanted to say something but i
was like i
people would just flame me for it like
there'd be too many people who were like
oh well you left man whatever they can
do what they want
and then then the unspeakable happens
then that russian porn
gets up there and it's on my page being
advertised to you know the apparently
millions of people that were like
trafficking to the page um and i was
just dude i lost my [__] man
i got freaked out i got my buddy sent me
a picture of it and i was just like
holy [__] like i made the video and i
was just appalled man and i
knew i think it was still that was gonna
happen do you think it was deliberate or
did you feel like it was gonna happen no
no no no
i think i think i do think that someone
probably saw
that the top whatever whoever was on the
top of fortnite
would be on my page and then definitely
did that for sure i think
i think that happened obviously it
wasn't twitch had nothing to do with it
but someone definitely was like oh [__]
if i if i do this
i can get on like the front of ninja's
page boom
and then and then oh dude i didn't
didn't the ceo
he didn't even apologize he he claimed
it was a uh
uh dude a freaking like a work in
progress
program that they were doing where they
recommend other streamers when you're
offline
i was like recommend other streamers
from top to bottom
literally number one number two number
three number four number five there's
nothing
proprietary about this this software
that they were it was literally just the
number one fortnite streamer on my page
then the number two and the number three
it wasn't like they were like
here's the an up-and-coming fortnight no
it wasn't [__] it was
top five guys who were live at all times
was being advertised
it was a total [__]
like a social network type moment it's
very like the facebook movie this yeah
like i can imagine a movie of your life
you're just your face being like what
the
[__] yeah i was didn't the ceo from what
i remember
that almost the day they announced the
mixer thing i'm sure there was a tweeted
laughing face he was he was um no
my my wife was like she like he we used
to work for
twitch okay so it was like he still had
it in his bio that he like
was like the president or something like
this he was like something like that
yeah
you're right but he wasn't currently
active at twitch it was a salty [__]
tweet oh yeah put out straight off the
belt
like a laughing face i'm like bro
there's a lot there's only one person
laughing right now when they're on the
way to the bank
yeah it's called kyla yeah dude and then
they handled you know shroud leaves and
they give them a perfect goodbye tweet
video and a compilation of all his top
clips and they're like we'll miss you
it's like [__] you man
i suppose you wanna i mean i i it's i
mean
i'm happy they're learning they they
obviously handle trod perfectly right
it's how they should have handled my
situation
um but i'm just salty about it as well
yeah because
because now they they know they can't
[__] people around the way they did yeah
when they leave no way right yeah
there's enough like why why would you
you know what you know this man i don't
know if you're a wrestling fan at all
but you you basically
created wcw www.e all over again like
there's now
two people fighting over all the talent
but that without you making the move you
were basically hulk corgan
you know i'm just creating the same it's
good there it is
when you're on a platform like we're on
youtube you can feel wedded to that
platform because you're like well that's
where my numbers are that's where my
people are
and a lot of people never think about
leaving the platform you're building a
home
it feels like a home version there's no
and you know it is there's no other
the way you [__] jumped over there
and dragged so many people with you it
was fantastic i was like
it's cool to be a part of it right now
it's not even stopping bro no because
also you're talking it was so fast
the amount of the rumors in the industry
no one ever really hears this in the
comments and stuff but it's always like
oh to to move people between platforms
is very very difficult
don't try and do that like people don't
even click on tweets to go to youtube
and things like that
so to shift that many people and then
also
the reason that people were salty was
not because you left and it was like we
didn't say goodbye to us it was like
oh [__] this is actually serious yeah
he's actually shifting numbers which is
a problem for them dude
i mean like let's just look at the
numbers bro like i was at by the end of
my twitch life i was averaging like
20 to 30k viewers every single day and
to be able to literally average 10 000
viewers
on on mixer is like it's astounding
that's because i like
if you look at it before i made the
switch mixer had five percent of total
hours watched for streamers
five percent so hypothetically i should
have had like 25
i should have 2500 viewers every single
stream and it's
it's actually incredible i mean i still
get people who are like only 8
000 only 9 000 i was like homie do you
know how like do you know how great that
is on this platform right now and it's
still growing
you're leading the build you know what i
mean so they need to accept that it's
exciting man and we're really working on
a lot of cool stuff to to just
obviously the you know take um
jesus christ you know just take
advantage of of the situation that
mixer's in right now and make sure that
you know we got some
you know great stuff coming out for this
i'll tell you what they could do with
the users in here
a live football show called the kickoff
oh wow that'd be great how awesome would
they be
uh if they wanted to info jordy.com
just give us a [__] we're gonna get all
those emails i could hook you up man
we're doing like 35k live viewers on
youtube
for our football show which is like
really because no one's ever done that
before so i'm very proud of that it's
really nice well so you're doing live
shows you're obviously
showing the show no so you don't show
the football we just talked we're not
even showing the football and these
[__] idiots watch us
at least with you it's like you can
actually see the [__] game with us
it's like we're playing a game or
watching again we're just going
that was good that's really good but we
have like a debate about of course of
course
obviously the content is rich and that's
great you guys should i mean just keep
ah keep going man that's really you guys
can do some really cool stuff with that
trust me
in football i feel like no i'm proud of
that you are looking for a football team
now am i right yeah i am and uh
any premier league club can come and
pitch themselves to you am i right or
are you sort of leaning towards no i'm
one hundred percent like
open so i would like to offer from my
team oh that's actually
they're so like the detroit lions be
honest i think there's more chance of
you buying my football team than them
sponsoring you
at this point i don't even mean sponsor
i just mean like some people should plea
for his
right like yeah yeah yeah i mean some
jerseys over you know
i'm going to send you a football shirt
let's do it newcastle united
newcastle brand comes from they're black
and white they're black and white it's
quite cool
detroit's a bit like yeah newcastle in
that sense you were born in detroit
weren't you yeah i was born yeah did my
research at cisco
yeah wow wikipedia incredible incredible
man
yeah yeah it didn't grow up there but my
whole family did and or my brothers grew
up
obviously until they're like four we
moved in i was a little baby would you
move to uh illinois man gurney been
living there literally my entire life
like a 20 mile radius
you know i want to talk a bit more about
the bronze because i i'm fascinated by
what you've done
because i'm trying to get as many
[__] big brandies as i can yeah did
you secure the bag no
what process because what i'm learning
now is
you need to basically work with brands a
lot closer you need
you really need over deliver for them
you need to keep them happy but you also
you need to learn a lot about what
you're bringing to the table yeah you
really need to know your own worth yeah
absolutely i
still struggle with that by the way i
mean
yeah you went from you know working with
smaller brands and now now you've got
uh red bull and adidas which is [__]
mind-blowing yeah what are you doing
with adidas by the way uh
i don't really can't wait we got we got
some really cool stuff so is it
like can you even hint that it's
clothing or trainers i can hint that
it's
stuff it's stuff that we might build
away the stuff that you might be able to
wear no way you're
breaking ground again without your desk
we can actually put this stuff on our
bodies you can put everything on your
body the process you went to though to
to go from the smaller deals to get
those bigger deals how did that
how did that transit because numbers is
one thing yeah but to be clever enough
and to be
have your [__] together let's let's like
i said big numbers are around
on youtube right ksi logan pewdiepie
they're all getting you're the one doing
these big deals
what were you learning in order to get
them i think bran i mean
brand safety is very important to big
those big brands
they're not going to take risks on
people who are just write that down
right right
you know uh if pewdiepie did a big deal
he'd probably have to sign that he
wouldn't go
near any bridges or anything like that
um no but for real like you have to
really
brand safety is huge and that's
something that i know is you know we
can't do anything too crazy too risky
um and you're a safe guy though because
yeah the [__]
i like that i like them i like that yeah
have fun man vigorously yeah but
definitely do yeah safety
again that's really the number one thing
man it's
in the gaming man like it like it's not
like it's not like i'm um
these top uh nfl and football athletes
that it's like
you just need you need to be sponsoring
the biggest guy because it's like that's
how you're gonna yeah
get away with it you can get away with
anything because it's like it's yeah but
gaming it's it's you kind of have to
we're playing catch up a little bit yeah
so the safer the better and one thing
i've learned as well man is
you know they're happy uh when you're
happy when you're happy they're happy
and and just to
to be passionate about doing the things
like you know i like doing the posts for
for rebel and like like when they're
like hey you need like an insta post or
like
it's like i love that [__] because i
love adidas and i love red bull so
it's not forced at all that's the number
one thing for me too like i wouldn't
take this i wouldn't have taken
any of these deals if i didn't actually
enjoy the products yeah because then
that's just fake and then you're it's
the whole then it's it's not even about
you're not passionate at all about it
then it's
literally only about the money and you
wanting to be with a brand that big
was there a point where you didn't think
that you get to that point though
because you aren't in such a lucky
position
every day of my life literally meeting
david beckham what the [__] is going on
you made me like dude i i was
a middle class
average white dude playing video games
like
what come on man like seriously like no
like my
my only aspiration was to just be a good
person like my parents raised me to be
and and to just live right i loved video
games i played them
i loved competing and fast forward here
we are
with a management team to get you into
those rooms oh
yes yeah you can't do this alone man
there's no way
my amazing uh loaded gg uh
they're they're incredible man and
they've been they're the number one guys
in the gaming industry
and they are now obviously getting
bigger that's how we're able to get even
you know
you got to know people too though right
i mean networking is the number one
thing
you got to go to the parties where
they're going to be at you got to be you
got to take the same drugs
yeah whatever it
i is a lot like i said guys a lot of
sacrifices yeah no
suck a lot of dick yeah there's a lot
there was a lot of uh a lot of peanut
butter there's schmoozing you know when
we call it
otherwise brian goes to parties and
everyone just goes is he growling i
don't know
i just i just drink a lot and i just let
lawrence go and schmooze yeah and then i
take them back over and he goes
i haven't having a great time this is
gonna be great
fight me oh for [__] sake
that must be a bit do you ever get put
in rooms i mean you must get put in a
lot of rooms with people
yeah where you are you ever having days
where you're not feeling particularly
sociable or you're sort of like
you know i think there are the only
there are some days where i just don't
want
kids in my green room and uh find a
dollar for every time i
was like all right this is your green
room and there was like a kid in there
waiting for me that like someone who
worked there like brought out
bro i'd sort of like i'd have a lot of i
had a lot of money because it happens a
lot
um but and and that's a [__] on though
like people shouldn't do that [__] yeah
you're you're not crusty the [__]
clown do you know what i mean
you've got the blue here yeah yeah yeah
you're marge simpson
people don't understand like even you
coming on here like i had some requests
you know what i'm saying and it's just
like i don't think people realize that
just because kids watch you doesn't mean
that your whole life is dedicated to
kids
right again i usually you know i'll
always take pics
whatever because i love it and obviously
like that's my fan base and stuff like
that i'll never say no because that's
just rude right i mean
he's he's in there already like let's
get this over with uh but no
there are some days where i just don't
want to yeah i don't want to go anywhere
i don't want to
say hello to anyone but i always will
and i'm usually always in a great mood
so those days never really happen
i was i was fascinated to know about
like
mentally how this has all impacted you
as well because um
you you seem really um like focused and
a solid guy yeah you know you take your
days off when you need to
uh have you had any issues with like the
impact of social media where you're like
this is just too
much yeah i had like my first like
anxiety attack the other day
like two weeks ago i've never really
fully experienced anxiety
i don't even know i don't even think
there's a lot of stuff it was just like
one thing that i was really worried
about
and i had to travel the next couple days
and and i was in the car with my wife
and i was just like i was like man i'm
kind of freaking the [__] out right now
uh and you know she just had to talk me
down everything right everything i was
worried about
but i'm usually really good as long as
it doesn't all obviously you know pile
up and [__] like that
do you ever say um like therapists or
anyone like i need to yeah i'd love to
because i'm starting to realize how
healthy it would be i'm starting to
realize that myself
like because whenever you like watch
high profile
people uh they always say yeah i see my
therapist like once a month or whatever
the [__] it is
and i'm like now realizing like when you
get to a point where like so many people
are watching you and
that give a [__] about every little
thing you do and you're under scrutiny
like yeah
it's impossible as much as we are like
strong-minded people
right to just walk through that you
can't i mean i think that i think that
i don't know a wise person said this and
i don't know who it was
uh i think everyone can use a therapist
man everyone everyone's got [__]
charlemagne the god
probably yeah i think he's big everyone
could use one but definitely when
yeah the people youtuber dude i think
every youtuber should have one
um talk talk that [__] out yeah uh but
some people
use their audience as a therapist oh my
god which i think is really it's quite
an unhealthy relationship i don't
don't like a lot of that content i don't
like when people are like those like
exposed videos and like they're like
talking like i don't know man your
audience is not your fans are not
you don't take advice from your fans
like i mean truly they're not
you they have not been in your shoes
like
you they they usually look to you for
advice so to you to comment
it's it's a web relationship very
unhealthy man it's very unhealthy
you they need to see a therapist if
you're trying to actually like get some
help not
the money coming into your life right so
you've you've obviously you
you said you'd come from a lovely family
background i watched interviews with
your family it seemed great
very well adjusted background uh the
money comes in
you've always had this like
determination like laser focus
but when money comes and you know you're
an athlete
yeah in in a sense has that changed your
level of like
i need to keep doing this as much and
win win win
absolutely i mean i want to just set my
family up and my friend and my friends
up for
for life i've been helping out we've
already helped out a lot of our family
we're going to keep doing that
but yeah i mean dad dude i just want to
keep i mean i just wanna i just love it
i love doing i love
making money it's awesome man it's great
so i don't even spend well i was asking
though
sorry i think i messed up no no just to
be specific though because for a lot of
people
when they get money boxers like the
motivation goes
with you i don't see anything absolutely
not i want to keep going now like i i
don't i don't want
a million brand deals i actually love
right now that my two big ones are
adidas and red bull
and i kind of actually like that a lot
of like the little ones are starting to
fall off a little bit
yeah because i can just focus on this
but yeah no way man i wanna i wanna keep
going
i'm never gonna i don't think i'm ever
gonna actually just like stop you gotta
build in the right way really right
because i
listen i have a fear i've said this
before i don't want
someone to come along and have done what
i've done i'm sorry
not have done what i've done not even
have come close to the things that i've
accomplished
but somehow be like remembered more than
me
and or people think that they're like
bigger than me
or their come up was bigger than me and
i feel like that will happen
i don't know why i mean legacy is
important
yeah man absolutely especially yeah 100
like i i like let's say just look at all
my stats
everything that's happened how many subs
have gained you everything
and then someone does like 20 of that
and then but people are like talking
like i don't know
oh man it's fascinating because
we we did it we had an interview with
one of the heavyweight champions of the
world
in boxing tyson fury last and he was
saying the exact opposite as you not
really and yeah i mean i'm looking at
two basic champions and this guy's going
i couldn't give a [__] about legacy
means nothing to me
but i just want to keep fighting it's
it's the fight that actually is
sucking me in but um no it's fascinating
because i'm i'm a bit more like
yourself in that uh i want to have a
body of work i want to i want people to
look back at what i've done and yeah
that was a [__] hell of a ride that
can be hard
because there is a difference between
hype and um legacy isn't that i think in
the moment some people get a bit hyped
around something and feel like they're
leaving a legacy
yeah and then you look back and you're
like oh i was just gas like i really
thought that i was leaving something
behind no i want to
leave something behind man for sure for
sure a lot because
i just i don't know people say don't
care what you think what other people
think about you
i very much care what people think about
me well we're in that industry yeah i
mean i'm
like being a good person and that my
you know my mom and dad raised me right
and like when i see people that don't
like me i'm just like dude i promise you
i promise you bro one beer with me and
we're best friends like and you know
people that's and
like to see when people are like man
[__] ninja i'm like god man
what have i done to sort of bring this
on other than be good
right and it's like i would love to know
why you think that and like i should i
pro
like two minute conversation bro and
you'll be like oh okay
but some people are just unhappy in
their own lives and that's where yours
is
that goal isn't it because yeah i get a
lot of tweets on myself and i'm like
this is a reflection on you this yeah
i barely you watch like 10 seconds of a
video of mine and you're going like
crazy yeah like 100 percent this is
about your life yeah
it's like 50 50 you're gonna have people
who are just like what you just said and
then people who genuinely have an
opinion
that and it's in both of them and it's
like listen you're wrong all right i'm a
good person
it's also you kind of be worried if
everyone liked you because i think then
you'd be a little bit too bad
right you'd be a little bit too but it's
you're almost boring if everyone likes
you yeah but
being a champion or being big or
whatever you do is going to bring that
hit regardless like we said about before
everyone wants you to lose once you
become the child but you know in terms
of like
you're talking about people liking you
you've got you've got a close circle of
friends
i see i don't need it i've yeah what
you're saying yeah so
keep going no i see you like gaming with
the kind of the similar people all the
time but are you ever worried that um
people might use you because of what
you've become starting to worry about
kind of feeling that effect a little bit
the last like year we were like really
analyzing
a lot of stuff and uh and watching i
mean listen and do
i'm and this is it dude like a lot of
drake's lyrics are
really really good for people
who are in his shoes yes like he he
talks about like
you know only caught like everyone needs
you when they're like you know
loves you when you're on your you know
you're the best you're on your way up
and then it's like but when i need
someone like no one's there for me
it's like it's so true man but it's
lonely
i mean it is lonely at the top i have a
lot of great great friends i'm really
honestly i
keep telling myself that because i it's
true man i got like tim and tatman my
boy
he you know he texts me all the time and
he's people a little bit like this guy
you do you do you guys actually shut up
he's a handsome guy yeah um it's just
like
i have good friends man who actually
care about me and that's great and there
are
but when people rely on you right
because there's a trickle down when
you're at the top of
a mountain almost you also don't want to
come across as weak
because they look up to you and
and and therefore sometimes i personally
sometimes don't feel like i can
be like that i have to be the strong one
do you ever i don't know about you but
do you ever feel like there's a little
bit of
a you can't show that sometimes um
yeah a little bit i think that to my you
know to the true ones the real ones i've
opened up a little bit
and that's nice to like you know be
reassured uh but yeah i know 100 yeah
you got to feel that that sense of you
know hard
you got to be the the rock man right not
the rock
dwayne oh dwayne uh no you got to be you
got to be like the
you know sturdy definitely because you
build yourself up you've you've
gone from tyler into becoming no one
likes being weak no one likes being
exposed
vulnerable yeah this ninja guy as well
though like you become this guy
and now sometimes when you become this
person
you don't want to go back a little bit
and be i don't know don't you know i
know exactly what you're saying yeah
yeah you want to always move forward
right constantly move forward always
before don't look back don't be weak
don't
uh kind of you know is it regress yeah
have people ever tried to sort of weasel
their way into your circle and
and get on the hype train have you seen
that i think a little bit i think a
little bit
like you're a great ninja yeah yeah like
the people who like invite
drake invite me every time i'm on hell
no
that was actually what i said man i i
was like oh man maybe i think you know
maybe drake like used me to give you
someone a little funny story about that
man someone actually like put that idea
in my head and that was actually why i
said it out loud oh
[__] he was like you were serious
weren't you for
literally for like five seconds so a
friend gus you up a little bit like yeah
he's someone i was hanging out with was
like listen man
he you know like he hangs out with all
the all the upcoming guys man just like
check like
bro like how did you not know you and he
was like yeah of course he used you
so like i was streaming and i said it
and i was like no no no he didn't
but i said that it was in my head and
then and then i was like wow
and then [__]
[Laughter]
i was like he definitely didn't he just
wanted a game
and it but i said it maybe he did a
little bit but not in it not in a
not in the way that it was put to you so
for example yeah jay-z
historically if anyone's got any shine
all of a sudden jay-z is collaborating
with them right drake is a student of
the game he's going to say like
when someone's on their way up now with
the game's trade from rap into just
everything social media
he's going to be like this is the guy i
i we both
when you collaborate in any way whether
it be on a song or in a game and you'll
come together to make a [__] special
moment happen like you two did
you're both gonna benefit right so as
much as drake is a big huge star
and you're you're a star in your own
gear but obviously drake is another
level and yeah
he's still going to benefit a bit from
you he's transactional yeah yeah
absolutely it's not like you're so but
the way
that the person was make was kind of
right but they probably didn't do it
very negative yeah i'll be honest as
well like that was the thing that
made you piqued my interest of you which
is obviously massive for yourself
yeah um but like right no dude he did so
much for him you brought records with
that [__]
yeah so do you want to apologize to
directors down camera
uh sorry i i've apologized i apologize
um it must be a little bit strange
because you're also just putting rooms
with other athletes right you're on espn
magazine yeah yeah yeah espn
that was cool actually i don't know if i
can say this i got offered
uh uh oh a
risky offer from espn you might you
might
but yeah just do the nike yeah i said no
for now really i'm gonna get ripped real
quick
i i don't know if i don't know very uh
it's kind of off brand so yeah sure
you're i haven't grateful my shirt off
yet but like this podcast is going to
get real hot there's other areas that
are blue if you know what i'm yeah
i've got it matches the drain
i've got a metal picture of him holding
like a control pad
yeah it's a good one the problem is
though when you're in those and i was
considering because
that issue is very eye-catching um you
you're alongside like you know nfl
players and right
these guys are to be ripped they're like
yeah that must be wild
it was man i i literally i dude i'm
again with the adidas thing i probably
kind of touched on this almost right
away i really do feel like i
should you know get in shape like i am
not out of shape
but i'm definitely not in shape and uh
you know to you're skinny fat it's fine
don't worry
yeah you're getting scared this is the
thing though right um
for your mental like side of things i i
bet
it would make you better at everything
in your life just a little bit a lot of
gamers
there are a lot of call of duty guys and
and and gamers that like
do they they it's like it's infectious
bro they just
start getting [__] ripped bro they
start eating like protein shakes every
morning and they're just like come on go
hit the gym guys i'll be right back they
come back like an hour and a half later
they're like all right and then like six
hours later i'm gonna hit the gym around
too i'm like what the hell and you see
pictures they're just jacked out of
their mind
like tony brought you something now you
don't need to go like that though i know
i know
once or twice a week's enough i want to
try this is one thing like i want to use
my money
wisely right i hate i'm never going to
blow it ever on like stupid [__] and
we're doing a really good job of that
honestly besides like we like you know
clothes i think that's probably what me
and my wife spend our most most of our
money on is honestly designers really
the tournament show oh yeah we love it
man it's great well yeah it's great
but just need to start using it like i
want i want to
i want a full-time chef man right who
will just make me the the healthiest
food
so no matter what it is it is impossible
for me to be unhealthy and be
like fat how do you eat right now like
because it's very it's 50 50 man i'll
probably say like fast food once or
twice a week
and then a lot of a lot of ubereats but
we make sure we have you know salads and
other like really healthy food i'm not
ordering you know super disgusting fatty
foods all the time sushi things like
that so do you get to see a lot of
you know when you're traveling do you do
you get to go to the places you actually
want to go to or are you just
in a hotel back out the hotel i love
love dinner and drinks i'm a huge huge
let's go out to a nice restaurant get
some great food and have some awesome
some beverages if you need some hookups
in london i know we had we hit this
place called milk and honey last night
yeah it's good huh
oh man it's good incredible cocktails
it's great so i like a mojito just a bit
more interesting
that fell out of context and it was good
well that would be clear though
get some drinks tonight yeah absolutely
for sure um we've got um
actually i've got one one question about
because i was looking in your journey
and i was like
where's the struggle here where's the
where's the you know what i mean because
everyone seems to have something because
when they're as determined as you
yeah and i found it quite interesting
that you had a detached record oh my god
at one point that was interesting no one
even knows
how shitty your eyesight is everything
yeah it says dude it was
really i think i want to say and i don't
throw this word around i'm pretty sure i
i was depressed for a little bit
for sure uh after the surgery i had to
be
so they put a gas bubble in your eye and
then gravity does the work so
how did how did this happen sorry just
no idea my mom's on my mom's side of the
family
there's like a history of of eye law eye
sight loss and like one
eye right and i'm pretty sure it's
because back in the day you couldn't
figure out what a detached retina was
so it just kind of happens you can get
it from there are like three things if
you have diabetes your higher chance of
getting it if you get like knocked in
the face
you have a higher you have a higher
chance of getting it so like so like a
lot of mma fighters and boxers if i were
them like i'd be getting my eyes checked
after every fight
um but yeah because if you discover
right away bro it's it's like a quick
little laser and you're done
like no recovery but mine was like full
fully detached like a couple more days
or weeks they said i would have been
blind
and uh in their in my right eye so like
they boom the surgery i had to be away
through the whole thing which is
terrifying
uh they put gas when you're i had to
look down for a month i had literally
all day 12 hours a day and then and then
for the first week of sleeping i had to
sleep with my head
down because the gas bubble when you
look down the gravity would push
up against your retina kind of like glue
right when you hold you know you're
trying to glue something yet so you have
to like kind of hold it down
it was terrible terrible dude [__] i was
alone in my apartment
for a month like just not moving were
you with your wife at this point
girlfriend at the time and she was there
for the first week jesus my brother
actually i always give my brother [__]
man he left he left me
for like a week right when it happened
he's like i'm gonna go hang out with i
think i don't know if his girlfriend was
going to see but
he left me for like a week so then jess
came down and like took care of me you
must have been pretty shocked though
i still can't see you out of my head
very well how frightened that was
terrified were you about the game in
korea
oh it was out it was just was it life
and terrified man i kept asking i kept
asking every time i went back and i was
like
well i'll be able to like really see out
of my eye like like actually good vision
and they never really could answer it so
they're like
i mean yeah i mean i can see like i can
literally i can see you guys
perfectly i can kind of read those big
ass letters and um
but it's bad really wow dude but always
people don't know as well man is like i
mean everything happens for reason thank
god because who knows if i would be here
today if
it didn't happen because i was streaming
the destiny beta and the alpha
i was getting like three four thousand
viewers yeah this was when i was getting
like 300
400 viewers playing halo and then when i
switched the alpha and the beta of
destiny i was
popping i remember i spent so much ready
bro you know what my surgery was
the opening day of destiny so when i
come back a month and a half later
no streams for a month and a half i'm
averaging like 300 viewers
again wow and i kept grinding for like
three months straight
literally 16 hour days no [__] and like
i started peaking at like 500
and then when other people and then
there are other people who are playing
destiny who are at like 8k
9k i'm like 10 times better than them
and i'm just like
god dude if only everyone where were you
during the open like oh
whatever man i know because the
competitor and you must have been like
you kind of see it yeah yeah dude i was
so pissed man
i was so let down bro like that's your
shot right that's like that's like
someone who's in college and they're
about to be drafted and then they
freaking
you know tear their acl or some [__] and
then they don't ever get drafted the
opportunity was ripped
oh it was right there oh destiny came
back though destiny
it's good yeah the bait i spent ages on
that beard it was so much fun bro
i loved it oh man what a missed
opportunity though with like
destiny i mean i wish they i think they
[__] it basically they should have had
60 f or more than 60 frames i mean they
did a great job the pc is actually
good i like the game i watch it a lot
obviously you play the most fortnight
yeah what else do you actually enjoy
modern warfare new cod bro
love it love it great game gunfight is
the hands down the greatest playlist of
all time
just 2v2 one round like one life around
the
weapons are random it's so much fun yeah
i want to ask you a little bit about
your wife
i'd love to that seems to be like when
we looked at the
the research that we did on you this is
the sort of turning point almost a
little bit
um what impact did she have on you
everything man she
she's everything she's supportive
supportive uh you know
uplifting kind smart
she she i i'll never forget the day i
was playing
uh you know when she decided to manage
me and and i was playing
h1z1 i was in the middle of the game and
i just like auto i was on
auto run and i all tabbed and i was
answering an email a sponsorship email
while on stream while playing a game
because i you know i didn't have his
and it was with uh it was a g fuel and
uh
and i was averaging like 2 000 viewers
so like i was definitely starting to
upload with h1z1
and they were like yeah we'll give you
like a percentage of what you sell but
we won't actually pay you anything at
all of your salary
and and obviously and like oh yeah and i
didn't send the email yet in my response
but i misspelled like eight words and
just looked it over and she's like tyler
what the [__]
yeah like i will do this i will handle
this video if you want i was like please
and then she sent like a super
respectful email back and and
um fast forward now you know jokes on
you
but that was the moment when she started
to manage me
and now dude i mean i'd be lost without
i think a lot of streamers say that
a lot of like about their wives when
because
you do we're just we're in our own world
man for like eight twelve hours like we
don't know what's going on like i could
come upstairs and they could be like
yeah dude nuclear war is going on right
now
you missed it like because you just
don't you're really just out of it when
you're streaming
and she just keeps me in the loop man
every day love her to death man
it feels like they need to be a [__]
seriously understanding partner
to be a part of what you go through
because dude your priority special woman
you're the you're the star you're the
priority and like
some women some husbands some men
whatever they just can't be that like
player
who is assisting like it's incompetent
it takes a lot of give
a lot of give give give it is a lot of
give man the great thing is those i see
there are a lot of women
that come up to her and guys that come
up to her and we're out and they're just
like oh my god jess
i love you so much and i think that's
all that's that's that's all she that's
all she cares about
like is that she's just so happy that
she's
people are looking up to her as well if
not more looking up to her then they're
looking up to me and she loves that
because obviously who wouldn't um and
she does a great job man and
it dude you're right it takes a special
special person
to do to understand being with a gamer
and a streamer because she's been with
you for a long time as well we've been
together i think
seven years now and it's not like blow
up and then some model come along
so many people don't know about that
either man she gets comments on her
instagram
gold digger i'm like what the [__] yeah
she talks about it all the time and we
it's dude we love each other we loved
each other before everything
and here we are man it's like good
investment
yeah you're kind of like uh yes i guess
you're like gaming royalties as
king and queen there i like that dude
paul we we talk about it a lot because
we love the word man like power couple
like i love i love what i do i love how
i do it and i love what she does and
she's just
she's she's a strong woman man like i
cannot explain how much of a of a [__]
i was
like in terms of handling situations and
like my communication was terrible
before i met her and she just made me
uh just smarter happier and more
intelligent
and she changed my view become a man
sort of thing 100 man i mean i used to
have
the stupidest views on a lot of like
controversial topics
and and like and now she's just dude i i
just
i mean i've always been about quality
obviously but now it's everything man a
happy person everybody just live your
life and just don't you know don't be a
little [__]
she seems to have foresight like she can
really see
what things are going to play out type
things she taught me yeah i mean she i
run all my tweets by her everything by
her because she'll just be like tyler
let me tell you how they're going to see
[Laughter]
and i'm like no you're wrong and i'll
tweet it out and then she's like delete
it delete it delete it the first like
four comments aren't what
you like [__] she's got it down that's
handy to have someone who's got that
ability to look down the street and
around the corner for you
because um a lot of people just don't
have that around them and that's how you
see
uh influencers [__] it up for them
dude
a lot of passive aggression here but
fair play all right a lot of you know a
lot of youtubers that
you know i mean the paul's and they're
they're they're girls aren't these
geniuses who are like
i mean but then again you don't even do
like i i don't even know what they they
probably just do it all for the for the
for the [__] i mean like they get their
names out there like i think they know
they
they're women and they're like if you do
this like it's kind of below
so like i mean technically they're kind
of like well after getting to know the
the paul brothers i don't think jacob's
a flying [__] no
if i'm honest i don't know his wife
doesn't
of leaning towards that um he's he's on
a smart road now
i can't believe the difference in his
energy in just under a year since you
did the podcast with him yeah before and
then the party yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i just sorry i i think i mentioned that
i discovered you and you were doing all
the interviews and [__] for their first
fight
yeah super awesome man dude i'm i'm i'm
happy for him
logan i want him to not mess up he's
he's doing a good job right now
he's in a good spot good guy you know
that's the thing that people haven't met
him yet
i haven't met him yet i wouldn't say
this unless i really [__] believed it
he's actually some of the weirdest [__]
though yeah i mean he's odd but you know
he's a good he's actually like in his
heart he's not a bad person
but my god has he [__] up before but
yeah he's actually
he's writing it i would just like to
yeah i would like for him to do some
good stuff
right i feel like yeah that is be a good
influence
do some you know like just do good
things and and
that would be great and then don't just
come off as the cockiest person on the
planet
which is what which is unfortunate
because they're actually we're in the
business of
being a little cocky [__] that's exactly
what it is when you're especially when
you're boxing right like
oh man i just want a good fight no i
mean you got to talk [__] so like it's
kind of unfortunate it's a bit like you
when you were streaming back in the day
oh you have to give it you know what i
mean
do you feel do you ever watch your own
street because brian's very
self-critical and a lot a lot of people
are self-critical
how often do you watch your streams back
and sort of go i need to fix this and
never watch my own streams man
i watch like my youtube videos because
my editors do a great job and like they
mess around with a lot of you know
effects and i want to see how the videos
are
um no i don't like i don't like watching
my own stuff
wow i like those like the the actors who
don't like watching like i don't do i
don't
besides family feud i love watching my
family feed episodes because i love
family feud
um but uh when do you want that yeah i
do i was uh i'm
there's only two people in the world who
have been on the regular family feud and
the celebrity family feud
ah yeah i was second thought
so much
what's the game you're best at for
tonight no family feud bro we killed me
and my brother are fast money
legends man we we killed that [__] yeah
um no but i watched back a lot of my i
mean
i was on matt singer i was didn't i
didn't want to watch my episode
i don't want to see myself on tv like
surreal in a way yeah
i am on a movie though with ryan
reynolds i have a scene with him which
means
it's called free guy it's coming on
2020. trust me it's going to be a dope
movie they have a lot of top youtubers
gamers and streamers who are in it it's
very authentic
i thought you did really well on that
very authentic yeah well you want jimmy
fallon on one of those guys my boy
fallon dude yeah you did well
one of the nicest guys man just a good
dude i love fallon
love him i've been out there three times
now looking back at your life let's say
they make this into a movie um and you
know how um
you know in the journey movies which is
definitely what you're on there's a
there's a turning point
there's a moment which uh sort of seems
to be the switch or the the difference
between
the where the journey was going and
where it ended what would that be
for you that turning point switching
from competitive halo
to h1z1 and streaming that game that
changed that set up everything
battle royale's like i i mean i guess i
kind of got lucky
not really luck i'm kind of maybe like i
got on the hype of battle royales like
right when they first started out
hmz1 was the first big one that really
popped off and and that was when i i
was just playing the survival mode i
wasn't playing the battle royale i was
just like running around
killing zombies and like it was really
fun and i mean i saw like an immediate
viewer increase
after like a week and and that was
definitely the light bulb that was the
light bulb for sure
my brother man he's so smart chris he
told me forever he's just like tyler
you're so good at every video game
you're so funny
stop streaming halo stop competing in
halo
start playing popular games and and
you'll blow up and
i was like it feels like your brother
had was part of the turn he's a genius
man chris is so smart yeah he and he's
been he's been a huge supporter of me
too my brother john supports me too but
one of your brothers was really good at
halo as well am i right um
you know john would tell you he thinks
he's getting halo uh i watch interviews
with these guys they're like yeah he's
number one but i'm like number three in
the world i was like
that's john man he's so silly dude no
man no i've he's never been better than
me at any time
i was 11 years old whooping his ass in
halo 1 he would drop the controller in
the middle of the game when i'm running
the flag back
and then beat me until i dropped the
controller so that he could respawn and
then get you know catch up to me and
return the flag
wow bro he's he's been he i've been
better than him forever and he knows it
i love you john
all right my next question
and it's a bit morbid but i i was just
thinking about this last night because
of what you do every day
if you die tomorrow let touchwood
doesn't happen
do you think you would have any regrets
because
some people obviously not our age group
but some people would suggest that
spending the length of time not to get
not gaming but the sheer amount of time
that you've spent
gaming wouldn't be really making the
most use of your life that you could
have done would you regret
not going out and doing other things as
much and focusing
so much just on sitting in front of the
screen gaming
no way man i love everything i love my
life bro i don't regret
anything man if i would if i wish i
wouldn't even change anything
i want to go back if i go back i'd just
love to live it again like i loved all
the games i played growing up i have so
many great memories my best friends
like landing and [__] there's i i mean
hell no man i thought you might say that
i just wanted to know
um flossing with so many people oh [__]
bro you had to bring that up
one regret one regret dude i'm so sorry
i had sex
in new york city yeah jesus christ my
heart went out to you for that i felt
like someone had died
in my team and
and then and the new year's guys the new
year's team
right the team they're like listen oh
dude they're all gonna dance with you
man
they they're out there they're wearing
diapers they're [__] themselves
they'll do anything trust me
they'll floss with you that's not that's
not a good thing is when people are out
there wearing diapers
do you know my mate rory our mate rory
who just convinces you of any old
bollocks but it's not true
so they're bullshitting you at this
point and i was like are you sure trust
me
oh god go out there and no one's dancing
and then i i [__] dude oh i should have
read the room man
that's a big room i should have read the
room i was walking through
everyone's just no one's moving on the
way up there
everyone's just like cold as [__]
pouring rain
come on everyone come on i'm not seeing
enough movement oh my god
oh sort of it's like
i think you have to have those moments
in life though like it makes you like
when when we get embarrassed like i've
had some really embarrassing moments
online like you just have to [__]
like own them
and move on i learned that real fast
it's a bit of that ellen it's choked a
little bit for a first for the first
year
did you not nail the floor oh no i went
against the ligma and [__] you know what
i mean i mean that was so stupid to me
there's i mean there are like lit but
you know i mean i learned from that
right and so when i went that's i do i
tweeted i was like god i need to tweet
i need to make fun of myself immediately
yeah i ran back up to the room grabbed
my phone i was just like
don't ever do this [__] like okay it was
so good
if i would have went against that man i
would have been me i honestly i might
not even come back from that
yeah true truly like honestly if i went
if i yeah
yeah if i went yeah it would have been
bad but you know everyone kind of still
just like the throat around
like you might in my chat my boys when
i'm gaming they're just like you know
all floss in the game like in fortnite
and they're just like two ninjas we're
not on new york
i'm just like that's your move though
because when you're
when you when you're doing so well those
one times you do fall over like people
remember because it's so rare that it
happened so i
i guess take it as a compliment as well
like yeah yeah good one one of my
favorites
flossing in front which hey dude listen
as a bucket list thing bro i've never
been in new york city for a new year's
and i was not i was a part of it bro
like i was up there like that was cool
as [__]
that i remember we were like watching
like this guy's taking over the [__]
world
it's what it felt like yeah no it was
like that for us too though yeah
it wasn't like you were the only ones
you were just living it do you
with those sort of things do you get a
lot of advice from obviously you got
advice from people around you but when
you meet other athletes or other people
you get much advice from them or is it
just literally not real i mean listen
dude
i'm older than 90 percent of the
athletes in in the in the world
besides i guess football is a little bit
older right
yeah it can be but yeah man dude i mean
nfl
bro they're 90 90 are they're kids i'm
not gonna advise them they don't they
don't they don't even know
who do you get advice from i don't
really get advice from anyone man like i
really like i've had like i mean
mellow a little bit with like to like um
just not there's not not no one really
man
do i don't hang out with celebs
literally jeffree star man
great dude really what the [__] is he
like because he comes across as weird
he is funny as [__] bro literally
you want to just he just he just smokes
all the time
and uh and just is the nicest dude man
and just
though honey it's hilarious it's very
funny he knows how to be you know
my favorite part is like he's obviously
like hey guys how are you like welcome
and like it's funny like when i look my
favorite part we're hanging out is when
he'll just like
like what the [__] you shoot at me like
he like brings back his really
the real jeffrey comes out you know what
i'm so funny dude
this is jay i called him i called him
jeff i called him jeff on accident man
and he was just like dude i was like
sorry bro
and he's just like he comes across as
quite like flip-floppy on people that's
the only thing that would
i'd be wary of a guy like that because
i've seen him if you cross the street
so nice to people and then be a [__] to
them within a [__] minute
we don't listen one thing i know
especially hanging out with him and like
some of the [__] that goes on that isn't
talked about
all right when you flip on someone it's
because he's been crossed man
all right so there's it's deeper than
what he's like in the makeup industry
bro i i mean i've been
it's dude it is dude it's it's
dark [__] bro you there's so many i mean
no and no one is
really rooting for you in the industry
like oh this palette is so
nice and it's like deep down they're
like i want my own palette like
it feels like that because all right
let's become
because it's like a [__] place because
of the nature of the characters who go
there yeah and then because they're
fighting
over tens of millions of pounds like
yeah
it's for keeps they they're not to them
as much as it's funny to me because
they're [__] arguing for me
it's so serious because there's so much
money on the line yeah
i mean dude yeah shane bagged like 20
mil or something like that
that rubbed me the wrong way though
because i felt nothing i was a little
like i'm like all for him making money
yeah it was the setup
i felt like this documentary that they
made about it i felt like
they're like oh maybe i should release a
makeup line by the time we've got this
edited
it'll be ready to launch the day we
finished the last episode incredible
like don't get me wrong as a marketing
campaign
dude genius but don't round break don't
lie about the fact that you're just so
happening to decide on this halfway
through a documentary yeah tell us at
the start
we're making and we're going to go
through the whole process together
instead of like
i felt like that was just a light and
they were telegraphic i think that's
that's just shane
that's just shane being dramatic bro
yeah he's just he's that's him man he's
super super
dramatic i've spoken to him before about
that yeah
it's just who he is man yeah he's never
gonna change and he doesn't you know he
shouldn't change
that's that's what he likes to use he
makes he makes youtube a new thriller
you're making makeup [__] it was 20
minutes of just
i loved it though man it was fun my wife
loved that that whole thing too but
i mean watching it it took me a while to
like really get into it and then once i
actually started it seeing him like
start to dive in and actually learn how
to do the makeup well
shane dawson is a bit of a genius right
so i'm not trying to take anything away
from courses
but if you could just start the
documentary when it starts and not
film every [__] like picking what
food's in your teeth for 45 minutes
thing was hilarious we were watching the
first episode i literally looked at my
wife
the first 30 minutes of that i was just
like yeah get on the plane chain this is
but we also know he's getting off the
plane because we've seen him afterwards
it's not like we don't know if they're
playing crashes
i mean it's he's a goofball man come on
get on the plane chain yeah
you're gonna be all right we don't know
it's anxiety though you know maybe he
truly could have been terrified and he
wanted to portray that in the show
and the you know on the documentary
maybe someone related i give it up to
him he's been here for a long time and
he is one of the top creators
literally an og bro yeah i mean it's
crazy to see how he looked like 10 years
ago he's been doing this [__] for a long
time so good good on him for finally
making his nut i've got one last
question let's go bro
i have to take a massive dump all right
that's fine like oh my god he's going in
such a long line of people who've taken
massive shits after a podcast
we'll make it a good one though all
right let's go how would you like to be
remembered oh just uh one of the
greatest gamers of all time man
if not the greatest but that'll
definitely not happen because
again that line like what we don't again
we kind of don't really know what
like competitive gamer streamer like
what what
where would i be but just as long as
it's like
yeah man i mean he was like the first
you're you're in the hall of fame i
think we can
guarantee that as long as i don't [__]
up man let's go bog you know
just be i mean it shouldn't be hard you
know just i'm not a bad person so as
long as i don't do stupid [__]
and that you know is against my
character i think i'll be all right do
you do you think you'll always be in
gaming or do you think there'll be a
point where you cut out
i mean i'm already in some movies now i
think i'm in two
one i don't know if i'm in the other one
yet expendables
let me just get ripped out of my mind
give me like a year bro but it's not
only that he's not he's not actually
with them he's just flying a drone yeah
that would be something the guy i'm the
guy in the in the you know behind the
computer yeah exactly you're in the info
center instead
yeah like it's time sylvester to drop
out the bus and he's like you're getting
the wheel off i'm just saying we can
write i want to be
i want to do everything i want to do
everything and anything but i'll never
fully leave gaming i will be playing
video games until i'm dead
it's been an absolute pleasure you've
been fantastic this has been great man
like i could literally do this every day
yeah
we do it's fantastic it's great it's a
great life you've been a great guest i
really appreciate it i really do thank
you guys for having me man i really want
to be here so
yeah we'll do another one soon i'd love
to i love you yeah drinks tonight
if you haven't already subscribe to this
guy on mixer and go and check them out
and all of that sort of stuff and uh
you're going to know it's a big spike in
numbers yeah hey
we do good numbers yeah we do like the
podcast subscribe to us thank you very
much we'll see you later thank you guys
dude you guys are great man seriously
holy [__] i had so much fun
can i just say that was better than any
other overview you've done
hey i'm gonna advertise that [__]